on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
tonight up here's Morgan uncensored
Market Mayhem there's a pound tanks
against the dollar as Britain's big tax
cut gamble failed
after their momentary Truth for mourning
another weekend of Revelations on the
Royal Rift is there any Road to
Redemption for Harry and Megan
and golfing Legend Greg Norman is of
exclusively on the biggest Rift in World
Sports
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored well good evening from London
welcome to Piers Morgan uncensored the
conservative party used to be seen as a
safe Pair of Hands for the British
economy right now those hands are
throwing down cash at a roulette table
and it's not their money it's yours with
their massive tax cuts mostly for the
rich prime minister list trust and
Chancellor quasi quateng have taken a
reckless gamble with our economy and so
far that gamble is failing the pound
tanked to an all-time record low against
the dollar today that's not just some
kind of psychological blow for the
nation or an inconvenience for tourists
but simply it means you will get poorer
it means the things Britain sales get
cheaper the things we buy get more
expensive including energy in the middle
of an energy crisis it means the cost of
borrowing Rockets too at exactly the
moment that this trust plans to spend
more and less tax and tax less all by
piling up billions in debt well yeah
going to be an economist to find all
this pretty terrifying but plenty of
economists do find it terrifying what's
happening today is nothing less than a
massive vote of no confidence in the new
prime minister from the markets so one
of the Rory rumors swirling among Tories
writing letters of no confidence in it
it's all smacks of Casino politics
and the trust is rolling the dice with
our entire British finances meanwhile
the bank of England Governor Andrew
Bailey sent out to put out the fire
managed to inflame it by telling us he
won't hesitate to raise interest rates
in a statement in which he said he was
hesitating before doing anything
maybe the people supposedly in charge of
our economy do have a secret Ace up
their sleeves but right now
I wouldn't bet on it
well joining me now it's former
newspaper is Emily Sheffield join us and
broadcaster Jenny Clement former
director deputy director of the
international monetary fund Muhammad
alere welcome to all of you and Muhammad
I really wanted you on the show so thank
you so much for coming because a lot of
this is simply too complicated for mere
mortals with minuscule brains to get
their heads around you have the biggest
economic brain I've ever encountered
um put this into perspective how worried
should we be about what is happening
we should be worried and it's for the
reasons you've cited as of today the
market has lost trust and confidence in
the government's policy so that's going
to mean higher inflation that's going to
mean higher powering costs and that's
going to mean a higher risk of a
recession so we should be worried and
the government should be worried
in relation to this massive tax cutting
plan that they announced several days
ago it just struck me as a bizarre thing
to be doing given the current financial
crisis to start slashing taxes left
right and Center I mean do sharp-minded
economists like you did it make sense to
you
I think the overwhelming view among
economists is two parts of that of the
package with sound one was not what was
sound is structure reform to promote
economic growth
price stabilization for energy was sound
what was not sound was the size of the
tax cut the fact that they are totally
unfunded and they're coming at a time of
global economic volatility so the timing
and the scale and shape of the tax side
is what has caused this turmoil in
markets and what's causing damage to our
economy watching what's happening to the
pound and I can remember uh 2007 a I was
in America when it was two dollars eight
cents I think to the pound and this
morning I wake up and it's one zero
three
how low can it go and how how
significant is the value of the pound in
all this
so let's start with the second question
it is significant because we import a
lot and it's not just weakness against
the pound we also do against the dollar
we also depreciate it against the Euro
so everything we import is going to cost
us more
how far can it go it'll depend
ultimately now on the bank of England
the bank of England is in a lose-lose
situation not of its own making peers
what it should do to calm markets is
hike interest rates and Hike interest
rates aggressively we're talking about
at least one percentage points in an
emergency meeting not wait till next
until November when they next meet but
do it in an emergency fashion that's
what they should do but if they do that
they're going to be contributing as you
rightly said at the beginning to the
higher borrowing cost the alternative is
to do nothing and just wait but that
risks further Market turmoil and the
market forcing them
later on can any government and they're
very new to this this trust in
quasi-guating obviously and he just had
their jobs for three weeks can any
government actually withstand this
failing in other words if this massive
gamble which is what it seems
fails and say the pound starts Crashing
Down Below parity to maybe I don't know
you know who knows how far I can go
um and the general reaction from markets
worldwide is that we are now a complete
economic Basket Case could a government
survive that do you think a British
government
so that's more a political question than
an economic question economically we
have the following two choices one is to
continue with the gamble hope that
somehow the markets will come down and
wait till the growth impulse comes in
that's a high risk
relatively low return strategy because I
don't think it's going to materialize
the other one is to recalibrate the
package keep the good parts and change
the timing of the tax cuts say we will
look at these tax cuts now politically
that's very difficult to go back on what
you just announced a few days ago but
economically that's what they would need
to do yeah and I think economically
you're right I think politically that's
a suicide note and that's the problem
they've dug themselves into an
incredibly difficult position but my
bigger concern is the is the whole
they've dug the country into uh Muhammad
as always a brilliant overview thank you
so much for joining me greatly
appreciate it
thanks for having me
well we've also got former conservative
cabinet minister Ann whittakam who's
been listening to this and thank you for
joining the program
um most economists including our last
guest think this is one hell of a Gamble
and it could go horribly wrong
well it's beyond me how it can be a
gamble when you're taking a course of
action that also has already been proven
to work for example and this is a solid
fact and no Economist will dispute it
when Mrs Thatcher reduced the top rate
of tax from 60 to 40 and when far more
recently the top rate of tax was reduced
from 50 to 45 the amount the exchequer
took from that tax bracket actually Rose
so in other words it's a means of
raising money
that wasn't what Margaret Thatcher did
when the economy was in bad shape she
did it after she actually put up some
taxes and she put windfall taxes on
energy companies to get the economy back
on track then she slashed income tax so
in fact I'm glad you mentioned that
because people talk about list trust as
the new Thatcher I don't think Margaret
Thatcher would have ever counted as
taking the action Liz truss and
quasi-quarting have done right now
because when she faced a similar
economic situation she didn't do this
right now as you said to me peers hang
on
first of all what I was pointing out was
that we have tried on a couple of
occasions in the past and the result has
always been the same that if you reduce
the top rate of tax what you do is what
you do is you produce incentives to take
risks you reduce incentives to go in for
tax avoidance schemes you reduce
incentives to go offshore and you
actually get more money in and then can
we please look at the other very
unpopular measure which is the cap on
the bankers bonuses now there is still a
cap throughout the EU therefore without
a cap we become very very attractive and
what people forget is that the city
because the city never tells you this
because its PR is lousy it's worse than
the vaticans but the city contributes
not billions not tens of billions but
scores of billions in taxation if we can
get a thriving busy city drawing in yeah
there's one problem with that again yeah
my turn to say hang on again because
actually the last time we let Bankers
have unlimited bonuses we had the
biggest financial crash since the Great
Depression so that didn't work either
let me bring in my two other uh very
patient panelists thank you very much
indeed for waiting
um Emily I mean I my gut reaction is
this is a complete chaotic situation and
the the most frightening thing about it
I don't think Liz truss or
quasi-granting have any idea how this
now plays out they've Unleashed their
their bomb and now they're waiting to
see what happens
I think I thought Muhammad was
absolutely fascinating yeah because well
he really is an expert what he what he
picked up on is what quasi has openly
said his plan is he said oh don't worry
the markets will calm down at all come
good in a month it's just the city boys
having a go well he's directly
contradicting that saying no I really
don't think so that's unlikely to happen
and then
the thing I've been trying to work out
today
why why were they so confident the
markets were going to like what they
were doing because just arrogant Richie
Richie sunac made it very clear and
those clips are zooming around Twitter
at the moment he made it clear all
summer
you had to get a grip on inflation you
couldn't zoom in with lots of tax cuts
and a massive spend which by the way is
what Margaret Thatcher would have done
because mythology reacts very bad right
I mean Jenny I keep hearing Margaret's I
sure would she wouldn't have done this
she did the opposite the thing about
Margaret Thatcher is she isn't around to
say uh what what she said we know what
she did we know very very different
different and they all claim to be the
heir tomorrow
so this nostalgic time when everything
was great in the concern what do you
make of what's happened I think it's a
complete disaster I think it's it shows
how uh the lack of thought that's gone
into all of this it shows that the
markets have have no faith in the
government's economic policy and the
fact that Chris felt from from the
treasury tweeted on Friday it's good to
see the markets rallying around at the
one point when the parent when Sterling
went up that tweet is still up this
morning
and it makes the government look
ridiculous because they don't even have
a grip on comms nobody has said to him
maybe delete that one because this isn't
this isn't looking good at all I mean
for me it feels like there's a kind of
drunk person in charge of driving the
car quasi karting this morning when
reporters were following him around he
looked he looked terrified they looked
like they're a very inexperienced
government who does not know what they
were doing who are crossing their
fingers but I also think it's a
humiliating day for him I mean I really
think we should make that clear he
confidently said the markets will be
fine they relied on the advice of three
economists who said in many articles
over the summer a lot of them printed in
The Spectator markets will be fine with
this they're wrong the markets are not
fine with it he refused to have the obr
the obr said that if he was doing a mini
budget they would speed up their process
he refused that and now today he's not
only he's had to go back so he's going
to explain to the country in November
exactly what's happening what his fiscal
policy I mean and he's had to get the
opioid okay I'm going to come I can see
you shaking your head furiously but the
reality is the markets have voted with
their feet they're running a mile from
this plan the pound is tanking to an
all-time record low today all time ever
and how can you possibly put a positive
spin on this
that's right all time ever peers and
then it started to recover and you
carefully don't actually mention that
now
hang on no if you want me to be precise
here's what's happened one year ago it
touched 140 this morning it was 103.
it's it then went back to 109 and it's
come back to 107. I don't call that a
tremendous bounce back do you
no and I didn't say tremendous bounce
back I said it had started to recover I
cannot remember a single budget this was
the point I was trying to make uh in
which the pound either didn't
immediately after it rise or immediately
after it fall because the markets are
always jittery and for you to talk about
a policy failing on the day after it's
been announced it's just ludicrous this
is what time uh will tell and the only
thing I do think about this is that Liz
trust doesn't have that time because
it's only two years until the next
election
I think uh Emily Shepherd is that if you
look around Europe now a lot of
government changes going on and actually
a lot of reaction from the people of
countries like Italy and Sweden other
parts of Scandinavia and others reacting
I think to a few issues one economic
hardship secondly the ongoing issue of
illegal immigration around Europe which
has just not been resolved by anybody
and is getting worse not better and also
a sense that they feel like no one's
listening to them and they're
gravitating to these more populist
leaders like the new prime minister in
Italy uh what do you make of that I mean
my issue with it is we keep calling them
all far right I'm not sure this new
prime minister in Italy is what I would
constitute as far right far right to me
means Nazis he's not a Nazi she's a
populist but she's singing a tune that
is resonating with Italian people yes
and she her her Coalition is made up of
Berlusconi and Sal salvini salvini is
popularity dropped dramatically but
actually he had risen in popularity when
he stopped the immigration votes docking
in Italy so immigration I think is a big
issue for Italy I think some people
might see this government this Coalition
as more right than maybe is fair to say
because I agree with you I think they're
populous I do think they do have some
more right policies than we would have
here in the UK but salvini and
Berlusconi support Putin Jenny I mean
look people on the left they're always a
musical everybody who opposes them or
who wins an election like this far right
right they're all far right they're all
fascists they're all Nazis they're all
it's ridiculous hyperbole in most cases
I actually don't think it helps at all
but secondly there's this whole
undercurrent of the kind of ultra woke
ideology dragging the left extreme
places on a lot of issues where most
people don't sit and there's a
repudiation of that going on around
Europe I think yes if you look at what's
happened in Sweden if you look at what's
happened in Poland in other countries
there is certainly a failure of Social
Democratic parties to to make an impact
I don't know whether or not this is a
kind of reaction to wokism I think it's
part of it along with economic hardship
and have failure to deal with
immigration which I'm afraid has become
an issue it doesn't make you racist to
say there is a problem with immigration
the problem is there are millions of
people moving across Europe it has to be
done but nobody has a solution at the
moment
and the problem is that the the um you
know the the parties that are in control
at the moment certainly you know this
win in Italy today it's very easy to say
what you're against but then they
haven't really proved what they're for
and what their what their policies are
well she said she's well this is this
woman uh Georgia Maloney she said she's
for family she's a Catholic in a
predominantly Catholic Church as well
what she means is she's back to
old-fashioned conservative values I
think when I see her I mean when you see
Georgia Malone in Italy and you'd see a
traditional conservative or do you see
someone on the far right
a level
well it might be an effort to be
traditional but all I would say is this
and this isn't sarcastic it's it's it's
just a genuine
um comment uh it's a governments in
Italy don't last more than five minutes
you know they really don't and that's a
serious comment uh and what I would like
to see in Italy is a bit of stability
yeah I mean it's a one bit of good news
the Royal Air Force is announced tonight
that mistakes were made with their
recruitment process this came after the
service prioritized hiring ethnic
minority and female candidates over
white men to hit impossible diversity
targets they've now admitted this was a
strategic failure which is good because
it was it was a nonsensical way to go
about recruiting people to fight in war
um one final Thing Before I Let You Go
Pack crickets not probably your number
one subject but really it's not about
Cricket I want to show you something
that happened between the England
women's team and the Indian women's team
it was a crucial stage of the game at
Lords the home of cricket my favorite
sporting venue in the world and England
had one Wicket left so they had two
batsmen left they were chasing down a
score they were doing well and then the
Indian bowler did this
thank you
[Applause]
and look at this again in slow motion
the rule is
if a Batson's out of their crease which
is that area with the white climate in
that and the stumps they're out of their
crease Ebola is technically allowed to
do that but if you watch it in real slow
motion a bat was still down there when
that Indian bowler went into delivery
straight and I'm sorry that's just not
cricket and what I mean by that is you
can have laws and the law was changed
recently to allow that kind of run out
but there are two types of cricketer now
in the world there are the type that
thing that's acceptable way to win a
match and there are other types like me
and actually most right-minded Cricket
fans and players who think that that is
a complete disgrace and I say shame on
the Indian women's team you shouldn't
have done that win it fair and square
you know when you get home tonight
you'll be looking in the mirror all of
you and thinking why did we do that
at least I hope you are anyway
do you have anything to say ladies I
think you know Cricket is all about uh
honor and maybe we're living in an age
where you actually just need laws and
rules it's a very strange game cricket
to someone like me that you could rub
the ball but only in a certain
ways can I ask if this if this was
reversed Britain had won by doing that
no I wouldn't like it talking about this
it's called man cadding and it goes back
to when an Indian player called mankad
did it actually in a game I've never
liked it
someone had pulled that stuff when I was
playing in the East Sussex league for my
team Newegg so I'm going to pull that
stone punches would have been thrown so
you can get away with it but I think
they should put another laws you're
allowed to punch people to do it very
strange games
anyway thank you to my panel uh Jenny
you're going to stay I think aren't you
talking about sports watching ironic
still ahead tonight Harry Megan and the
palace insiders who know what really
happened look at those bombshell
Revelations from various books including
that Megan apparently thought she was
going to become the Beyonce of the UK
and pigs will be flying over the studio
also tonight our exclusive interview
with a man behind the most bitter split
in World sport golfing Legend Greg
Norman the CEO of the Saudi back lived
golf tour talks to me exclusively
tonight
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to Facebook at a moment
we'll be discussing whether there's any
way back for Harry and Megan first the
biggest but the World sport right now
involves the saudi-funded live golf tour
which in the words of Rory McIlroy has
ripped golf apart the study tools
included a series of superstars with
massive pay packets and has taken heavy
criticism for supposedly whitewashing
the image of the Saudi Arabian
government well Greg Norman the all-time
golfing Legend is the boss of Liverpool
and I spoke to him and began by asking
how this Almighty split can be resolved
well I think over a period of time it
will resolve itself peers there's no
question about it um look in the let's
just clarify this split I think the
split or this animosity has only come
from one side of The Ledger quite
honestly so what we've done is just put
another competitive platform for the
independent contractors which is us
which we've always been I believe
independent contractors have a choice
and have a right to go somewhere else
and play the game golf we tried to reach
out with the European tour we tried to
reach out with the PGA Tour we wanted to
integrate ourselves within their systems
to show that what we have is additive to
the to the sport of golf but they made
the decision not us when you hear
someone like Rory McIlroy he's one of
the top players in the world right now
without any question and a very you know
passionate and eloquent defender of the
PGA Tour when you hear how scathing he
is about what you're doing what is your
what's your message to him
well my message is Rory you're an
independent contractor you have the
right to make your decision remember
Rory started on the European tour then
Rory decided to leave the European tour
to go play where where all the money is
where I went to play to the PGA Tour why
did we do that pierce we did that
because that was the only option we had
as players hey Rory happy days do what
he wants to do you know if he's
comfortable over there doing that he's
an independent contractor he can if Rory
wants to go to the Middle East and get
appearance money to play in tournaments
Happy Days go play in those Rory that's
your choice don't begrudge the other
players for making the decision it's
just a shame that people have taken this
stance when you if you look back over a
period of time they're pretty much done
the same thing themselves do you think
that it's about morality or money and
the reason I asked that is I actually
wrote a column for the New York Post
about what I thought was the hypocrisy
about a lot of the sports watching
debate in the sense that the Saudis
already have a Formula One Grand Prix
they they own a Premier League Football
Club Newcastle they stage all the big
boxing baths and that none of that gets
anything like the kind of
or program that you guys have had for
setting up a Saudi sponsored golf tour
and I don't understand what the
distinction is I don't also understand
how the PGA if they're being honest with
themselves could say that they
themselves never do business with
regimes which wouldn't hold up to much
human rights scrutiny so I see a
hypocrisy there uh what's your view
about that look past you hit the nail on
the head hypocrisy the hypocrisy coming
out of this is so deafening it's
ridiculous
um because you're right the PGA Tour has
title sponsors that have a great
relationship and working relationship
for a commercial opportunity with the
Saudi government with pis so I don't
understand why it is that way sadly I
got an idea because we're the
monopolists I mean we're going in
challenging the monopolist which is a
PGA Tour it's been the one place to play
golf for the last 53 years all we've
done it is come in and shown another
opportunity another additive opportunity
now for the players to make their
decision oh my gosh I would have loved
to have that decision and I've given
these players who then live the
opportunity to grow their wealth and
give give them the opportunity to go
other places to play the argument
against what you're doing as you know is
that you're just throwing huge amounts
of cash at the top players many of whom
are taking it that the format of what
you do do is not as good as the PGA
because you don't have a cut system
there's no kind of losing if you like
there's just equal you know different
degrees of winning and also that at the
moment you're not getting many people
watching this the streams aren't getting
much traction if you think you're going
to rise above the Sport washing debate
to do what you want to do well 100
because 100 look going back to the money
issue right we've been the leader you
take live out of the equation the PGA
Tour would never reacted the way they've
reacted Liv comes along then all of a
sudden all this money pops out of
nowhere out of their Reserve how do you
think the players feel
that already they're on the level of
being you know decades and decades in
the game of golf even me included saying
why didn't I have the right to play for
this money if you've had this in reserve
all this period of time for just all of
a sudden pop up out of nowhere because
of live
you've got to ask a lot of questions
about that okay on the morality Point
I've seen a lot of your players some
handle it pretty well when they get
asked about this others have not handled
it so well some have been completely
buried like Phil Mickelson which I think
has been incredibly unfair actually and
I'm sad to see a legend of a game like
him be pilloried in the way that he has
but they're obviously legitimate
questions about the Saudi regime about
the murder of the journalists khashoggi
and so on you know are you free because
of your association with the Saudi
government in this way are you free to
be critical of their human rights
records and so on look I mean here's
what happened with khashoggi is
reprehensible but what we're doing now
is with golf in the game of golf what
we're doing is showing golf is a Force
for good across the world across all
platforms there's going to be questions
no question about it but we are a
commercial entity we're investing into
the game of golf we're growing the game
of golf and I'll say this here is I've
been away involved with the game of golf
for 45 years in that 45 years I have
never seen another entity willing to
step up to this to date and give us 22
billion dollars to invest into the game
of golf but again you know coming back
to my position as a fan I love playing
golf I'm a ropey 16 handicapper but I
love the sport and everything about it
what I I really am struggling with you
only have to give me eight aside yeah
exactly yeah
um no but and I've loved watching you
play over the years what I'm sad about
right now is you look at the major
tournaments for example if your live
golfers are not allowed to get ranking
points uh and then they can't qualify
for the Mages they cease to be in my
view proper Majors if you were
predicting what you think is going to
happen here where will we be in a year
or two years time I look I ultimately
believe there will be some merging of
the the powers to be to sitting down
having conversation we don't want it
right now because we've tried and uh
going back to what you were saying
before we didn't create this turmoil we
just came in with another opportunity
for the ecosystem within the ecosystem
for the players for the fans so we
didn't really start this big fight we
didn't create this animosity and with
the majors quite honestly peers they
should be Switzerland right if I'm a
major I want to have the best of the
best in my field they're the four Super
Bowls they're the four fa cups they're
the four whatever you want to call them
that should always remain up there
Switzerland away from anybody for them
to be dragged into this Quagmire
now there's going to be a lot of
questions to be needed to be asked about
that but they should be apart from that
if you're a broadcaster of any of the
four majors you should be saying to them
we want to live players in there because
26 out of the top 100 players right now
today are Live players there's 22 other
tour events in this world that get ow gr
points and I can tell you this 21 of 21
of those 22 are far inferior than what
the live tourism you know it reminds me
why are we being targeted you've been
snubbed up at the open they wouldn't let
you go to the Champions dinner which I
thought was actually very churlish as a
great golfing Champion a great sporting
Champion how are you dealing with that
kind of vitriol the kind of
disenfranchisement from the sport and
the official bodies that you that were
once so welcomed by how are you on a
personal level dealing with that to be
honest with your peers at times my heat
shield gets a little bit weak because I
am a human being I've done a lot for the
game of golf on number one player in the
world for six years I've done things in
the game of golf I promoted the game of
golf I've grown the game of golf
globally what happened in the RNA was a
petty cheap childish shot be honest with
you and if you can't Rise Above It All
shame on you because if you were under
the under pressure from other people
exerting pressure on you shame on you
for you not to sit down and have a
discussion and to understand what the
live business model is and to see how it
sits within the ecosystem shame on you
have you lost personal friends in in the
Gulf world as a result of all this 100 I
have yep but if they look if they want
to judge me on uh lack of information
and lack of what uh what's out there but
they're they're the ones with the small
mind I'm lucky to have these magnificent
people behind me I'm lucky to have an
investor willing to invest into the game
of golf like they are investing golf is
lucky to have this some people say great
so what people say they say you know do
you have any moral lying about any of
this at all in the sense that I think
some of your players were asked at a
press conference well if Vladimir Putin
wanted to set up a golf tour would you
allow that to happen would you want to
be involved in that in other words is
there a moral line that Greg Norman
wouldn't cross my moral line is I
believe in the product uh my moral line
is I've been a big storage composer of
growing the game of golf on a global
basis my moral line is golf is the Force
for good so I am so proud to be in this
role Pierce I really am because my whole
life somebody asked me a question the
other day Greg do you think this is
going to affect your legacy and I said I
mean you know what maybe my legacy on
the golf course is not my legacy maybe
my True Legacy is what we're doing with
live for the game of golf and giving
this opportunity to Collegiate players
to eventually to women to the guys we
have today to be a true competitor to
show that you are additive to the system
and our product is speaking for itself
and final question Greg I'm going to be
playing the the Saint Andrews old course
and Kings Barnes and Carnoustie in the
Alfred Dunhill links you've obviously
you know been very successful on these
courses in particular I had a bit of a
meltdown on the 17th the famous Road
Hole of the old course last year live on
Sky uh where I hit I think room 416 with
my t-shirt can you just give me a little
bit of advice with your old player hat
on for how I should play the Road Hole
well next time you hit room 416 try and
put it through that window and go exit
the other window that tells me you're
hitting the golf ball hard and long so
Greg Norman thank you very much thank
you very much peers
we're gonna debate what Greg Norman was
talking about there because actually
goes wider than golf it's really about
World Sport and this whole issue of
sports Washington can be done by
legendary boxing promoter Frank Warren
to discuss the hypocrisy or otherwise I
mean all and you'll have the latest on
Tyson Fury's potential Showdown with
Anthony Joshua at least I hope he will
horses like Revelation to Harry and
Megan were so diabolical to work for the
x-stars called themselves the Sussex
survivors Club is there any way back to
Royal life for all these sussexes
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
this is talk TV
foreign
before we get into the debate about the
Greg Norman interview that we just heard
uh this is the cover of the new European
newspaper which I think pretty well sums
up My Views about what's been going on
the last three days that is literally
trickle-down economics
a little bit never knuckle but I like it
uh before the break we heard my
exclusive interview with the boss of
Saudi funded golf tour Greg Norman who
described the hypocrisy of his critics
as Daphne well joining me now is Jenny
Cleveland again I'm legendary boxing
promoter Frank Warren who's recently
been in talks with the Saudis to Stage
potentially Tyson Furies next fight well
Frank great to talk to you
um what is your view about all this
because the Saudis tentacles in sport go
a long way now whether it's football
clubs whether it's golf whether it's
boxing Formula One and the allegation
constantly put up there is that this is
morally wrong
and yet I see Sports doing business with
all sorts of dodgy regimes all the time
that aren't Saudi Arabia what do you
think
good evening peers uh what do I think
about it 24th of May this year the uh
the then prime minister Boris Johnson he
he hosted the aim the Emir of Qatar
sorry of Qatar and
they they invested 10 billion in this
country 10 billion and the Prime
Minister uh said it it uh showed a vote
of confidence in Britain the trade deal
energy deal and defense deal
Boris went to
Saudi
um when the energy crisis started and
asked them to produce more oil he went
there on behalf of Britain so I the mess
the mixed messages going out I find
ridiculous you know it's okay for the
government to deal with them it's okay
for the government to sell arms to them
and yet we in sport shouldn't be doing
it so you know this where do we go this
our own government are doing it do you
think do you think the when you listen
to Greg Norman there do you think the
the splitting golf really is about money
more than morality that the PGA Tour the
big tour don't want to lose their best
players to the very cash Rich Live Tour
and you think inevitably there'll be a
deal and they'll have to come together
uh there I don't know it is about money
you know I'll be very honest if you know
most Sportsmen not so much with golf but
most sports and certainly boxers have a
very short career so using Tyson
hypothetically if he was to be offered
to fight say 10 million in this country
and he was offered 30 to fight there
I mean who's to stop him doing that you
know they've hosted you've said they
hosted um those various events Formula
One Etc WWE WWE regularly run shows
there the Italian and Spanish super Cups
have been host staged there on a couple
of occasions and then I think about the
other Investments that sound you've made
in other companies like EA
um Nintendo Walt Disney Uber and
Facebook yeah so I don't get any of this
I think a lot of people let me bring in
Jenny I mean you're shaking your head
here I mean I I saw this week a tweet
from James cleverley thanking Muhammad
bin Salman the Saudi Crown Prince of
those helping getting British hostages
out of the Russian hands in Ukraine
um how is it the weekend of the foreign
secretary thanking this guy if he's such
a pariah that we're not allowed to have
a golf tour sponsored by it because we
as a country are unfortunately dependent
on on Saudi Arabia by our arms we depend
on them financially in a way that I wish
we didn't when it comes to sports there
is a choice we don't need this
investment from Saudi Arabia it's not
like Saudi Arabia desperately cares
about boxing or about golf what they
want is to co-op some of the good will
we feel about sport to make themselves
look better and if you look at for
example Russia over the past five ten
years the Sochi Winter Olympics Formula
One uh all sorts of of giant sporting
events that that took place there and
returned the other way because at that
time with you know maybe Putin isn't it
is your position that we should stop
having anything to do in a sporting
context with any country that has a bad
human rights record I think a country
because you do realize that if that's
your position that will pretty much wipe
out most major sports in the world from
continuing at their same commercial
levels I think that sport has to rise
above it and it shouldn't necessarily be
about money when you're talking about
the most important in Saudi no sport in
China uh yes no World Cup in Qatar yes I
would say that too nothing in Russia I
mean when you're doing you're basically
saying right anywhere whose regions we
don't approve of it's not no no no which
I would put this to you after we
illegally invaded Iraq in 2003. would
should people have boycotted British
sport I'm not saying it's people whose
regimes countries the regimes we don't
agree with but you're saying countries
with an appalling human rights record
where people who oppose the government
are murdered where gay people are
murdered perhaps we should say no we are
not going to let you uh burnish your
image by uh by using even if our
governments continue to do billions of
pounds I think we should not vote for
governments that continue to do billions
of pounds I'd love to see the labor
party never do any business with the
Saudis particularly on oil let's go back
to Frank Frank I can't let you go
without asking Tyson Fury Anthony Joshua
there was a 5 PM deadline Tyson's gone
off on one basically saying that's it
it's off I think there's still wriggle
room is there still regular room
or Tyson's adamant he gave the uh he
gave that deadline on Friday and again
repeats the next Saturday and I think
even yesterday and uh he's he said
enough is enough they've had the
contract for over 10 days we've had
we've had conversations today with the
other side but Tyson's had enough of it
so
um you know that's it I mean he's the
guy he's the champion he's the guy that
matters
and he makes the decision and that's his
decision at the moment
do you think it's over
uh look um personally the only way it
could happen now if they sign the
contracts and and well they haven't even
sent back the contract with any
amendments on it so you know 10 days on
you thought we'd had something backing
up by now and there was positive talks
today but um it's just you know Tyson's
Tyson you know he feels he's giving well
a tremendous opportunity
my money paying 40 my bet is on this
fight happening and I've got another bet
if it does happen with Tyson Fury which
he made on this show live which if he
does get back in the ring I get a
million pounds off him so I have a
vested interest in this fight happening
well it's probably your fault it's your
fault it's not going on he can't afford
to
Frank brilliant to have you on the show
thank you very much mate much
appreciated Jenny great to see you thank
you very much indeed we're coming next
of course there's been more damaging
Revelations all weekend about Megan and
Harry and the big question I guess
remains now can they ever rejoin the
royal family the fur will be live next
to go for Tom bar and Royal Ellison
Katie nickel
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well welcome back it's been another pack
weekend of Royal Revelations and as
usual they weren't very flattering for
the Duke and Duchess of Netflix on
Palace inside a claim puppies to shine
Megan wanted to be the Beyonce of the UK
when she married Harry she reportedly
moaned she couldn't believe she wasn't
getting paid meeting the public on a
royal tour of Australian apparently the
pair were apparently so awful to work
for the ex-staff called themselves the
Sussex survivors Club that's according
to a new book by the times we're all
correspondent Valentine Lowe joining me
now is Vanity Fair Royal Edison Katie
nickel a royal biographer Tom Bauer well
this is the A Team if ever there was one
uh to take us to the end so Tom
so many new River relations but they all
basically boiled down to one question
is there any way back for these two
absolutely not definitely no I mean I
don't think they want to come back
either I mean they've made their Market
I don't think she does but do you think
he might I think he'll follow her I
think there's no evidence that they're
not a power tied to the hip and I just
don't believe I think the question now
is just how hard the book will be I
think Harry November Harry's book I
think is out for November because it
ties in with the crowns the crown on
Netflix I think Netflix documentaries
will come out as well they're amazing
it'll be explosive I mean if there's
more stuff in there Katie attacking
Charles Camilla the monarchy I don't
think I mean the British public are not
going to have it I don't think they're
going to be thinking really I didn't
Queens died they're still yapping away
YouTube I don't think the Americans will
have either of his I mean you know
obviously I wrote for Vanity Fair I'm
very tapped in with that International
audience and actually Tom and I were
just talking that you know after the
April interview there was a lot of
support for the sussexes to the point
that if people believe well exactly it's
the point a bit of a kickback against
our royal family but now everything I'm
getting on my Instagram feed on my
Twitter for all my vanish Fair readers
is if they go back now and literally
Chuck the Royals under a bus again they
can't do that and I think that's because
we've seen the new king be so welcoming
those Olive branches they're mentioning
them in their speech you know whether or
not they're going to get the titles
we've yet to see in my book I say that
you know by the way from new Royals I
mean the sauce is close to Charles say
he's willing to give these titles which
are right fully theirs because but it
comes with a caveat they have to prove
that they can be trusted and as Tom says
you know we're going to have
documentaries and everything in the
autobiography and there's Tom isn't it
it's kind of law of diminishing returns
if they keep just moaning about two
three years ago and the experience they
had at some point there's nothing left
to say but there's nothing else for them
to do that's the problem and I think
that the the ultimate will be he will
not make the children prince and
princess and then he'll say we're taking
away the Sussex titles yeah which I
would think we churnished last time I
put in your program I said so but I
think if they publish the book the way I
think if they're going to keep trashing
the royal family and the monarchy they
shouldn't have the titles if you want to
go and be celebrities and make your
money that way fine you can't do it with
royal titles I don't think no you can't
and I think we've seen Charles is quite
titles matter to him right I mean the
queen and the Duke of Edinburgh wanted
Edward to have the Duke of Edinburgh
title well he hasn't got it yet now we
were told by the palace that the matter
of titles would be addressed after the
official Royal morning period is over
but it's over now so let's wait and see
what happens but you know Charles is
very aware that he's riding on this tide
of popularity at the moment there's a
lot of sympathy there's a lot of good
will to royal family but that won't be
forever he's got a lot of work to do in
a short amount of time and I think he
needs to protect the right just you know
what he just doesn't need the headache
Charlie there's so many other people
have to worry though that's the problem
the honeymoon has been amazing I mean
the man who I when I wrote Rebel Prince
four years ago said he'd have a very
difficult problem becoming King that has
proved to be uh inaccurate in the sense
that he had a honeymoon he changed after
the book came out and he's done very
well but he's got a huge number of
problems now not just Harry and his
Andrew I'm sure there'll be more
Revelations about ever seen he's got the
problem of the Union he's got the
problem with Commonwealth he's got the
problem with the Palaces Financial fast
problems and the one thing he doesn't
need is Harry and Megan sniping from
well especially if as is rumored Harry
targets Camilla who's now the queen
console blaming her for the breakup of
his parents marriage and regurgitating
all that's all that could be very
damaging yes it could be and you know
especially with the new series of the
crown coming out well there'd be lyrics
I was just about to mention the crown
because interestingly and I put this in
the book the last series actually
Camilla watched with a large glass of
red wine I think Charles gave up after a
couple of episodes because it was
getting a bit too close to the Bone well
this is this new series going to be very
close to Bone and of course for the king
who wants to shed that 90s very hard
it's gonna be fascinating I'm sure we'll
be talking again thank you both for
coming in really appreciate it well
tomorrow night my one-on-one exclusive
interview with Jordan Peterson one of
the most fascinating and controversial
people in the world right now you won't
want to miss this that's one-on-one for
the hour tomorrow night well that's it
from me Keep It Uncensored good night
foreign
[Music]
Collins every day on talk TV there is
nothing we hate more than hypocrisy
discussing the big issues why was it so
hard to establish the deputy leader was
at a meeting with her colleagues the
callers Alan in Grimsby Tracy in Burton
on Trent Dave thank you very much
picking apart the big stuff this simply
does not wash look who's back under the
spotlight
this is talk TV news
good evening I'm Kate Partridge the bank
of England said it won't hesitate to
change interest rates to bring inflation
under control that's after the pound hit
a record low against the dollar
overnight prompting the treasury to
confirm it will set out a medium-term
fiscal plan on November the 23rd it
follows criticism from labor that the
government was accelerating the fall of
the pound with the promise of more
unfunded tax cuts the shadow Chancellor
Rachel Reeves has reiterated her
condemnation of giving tax cuts to the
rich in a speech at the Party Conference
in Russia at least 15 people are now
known to have died and dozens more
injured after a gunman opened fire at a
school victims include 11 children who
were pupils at the school in the city of
uzepsk that's all for now we'll have
more after the talk
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]